- [Interviewer] All right, Steven.
Steven, where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Steven] Massachusetts.
- [Interviewer] Boston?
- [Steven] Right outside of it. Franklin.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- [Steven] Franklin, Medway....
Shitload of places in Massachusetts.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
And you grew up with both parents?
- No. Just my mom.
- [Interviewer] Just your mom.
And tell me about your childhood.
How was your childhood?
- (indistinct) You know what I mean?
I stopped going to school in
7th or 8th grade because of it.
So, I guess it did overwhelm (indistinct)
- [Interviewer] So you
never went to high school?
- No, no, no, no.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- I went through two days, maybe.
- [Interviewer] Ah.
And where'd your life go from there?
- What did-
- To the streets.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] So...
to the streets, meaning what?
- Like, you're by yourself, you're....
Streets kind of sometimes
mean, too, I guess,
when if we don't have nowhere to stay.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And period.
- [Interviewer] Were you
doing drugs at that time?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What
was your drug back then?
- Crack cocaine.
- [Interviewer] Oh. And
what's your drug today?
- Heroin or crystal.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so
you kind of try them all.
- Right, right.
- [Interviewer] What do you do for money?
- Boost.
- [Interviewer] Steal? And sell?
- Yeah.
But just from stores.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Right.
And do you have kids of your own?
- Ah.... (Steven sighs)
Yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How many kids do you have?
- I have two.
(indistinct)
- [Interviewer] You have two kids?
- Yeah. One lives in Texas;
one lives in Massachusetts.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever talk to them?
- You know what I mean?
Your kids?
- Oh, no, no, no.
- [Interviewer] No?
Where do you stay now? Do
you live on the street?
- Yeah. (indistinct)
- [Interviewer] You have a tent?
- Yeah. Definitely.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And...
how long you been down
here? How many years?
- Since 2012, so....
- [Interviewer] About seven years.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And...
have you ever been beaten up, roughed up,
taken advantage of? Stuff like that?
- Ah, sorry.
- [Steven] No. I mean, no, not really.
- [Interviewer] You're a
white guy in the street.
You've gotta get picked on-
- [Steven] Right, right right.
But more people avoid it
than start a fight with it.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- [Steven] More people, I think,
would avoid it than try
to start a fight with it.
- [Interviewer] All right.
So, you've been okay?
- [Steven] Yeah. I mean, base, like,
totality of it all? I've
been pretty blessed.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have friends out here?
(car engine roars)
- [Interviewer] Do you
have friends out here?
- [Steven] Yeah. Ah....
Yeah, but, like, they're
not really friends.
You know what I mean?
Like, the ones that live uptown
all stay in sleeping bags.
You understand? Like
roots throughout the city.
So, that's what I was
telling you (indistinct)
- [Interviewer] All right.
Steven. Well thank you-
- [Steven] Sorry, sir.
- [Interviewer] Thank
you for talking to me.
- [Steven] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You got any plans?
You got anything-
- [Steven] Ah....
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] What
you got up your sleeve?
- [Steven] Huh?
- [Interviewer] What you
got up your sleeve? (laughs)
- [Steven] Yeah, no, no.
- [Interviewer] What are you gonna do?
From here?
- [Steven] It looks
like there's some things
going on tonight. You
know what I mean? So...
- [Interviewer] I'm sure there are.
- Right. It probably is. (indistinct)
- [Interviewer] All right, man.
- [Steven] I always keep (indistinct)
- [Interviewer] Well, good
luck with everything, man.
- [Steven] All right. Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.